hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 39 hört zu und
spricht nach der apfel ist gesund
der ab
öl ist gesund
die banane ist gesünder
die bananen
ist gesünder die orange ist am
gesündesten
die orange ist am gesündesten
stimmt das
ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
nicht ja das stimmt ja das stimmt
nein das stimmt nicht
das haus ist groß
dieses haus ist größer
und dieses haus ist am größten
das
wein ist schwer das
wein ist schwer die kuh ist schwer
die kuh ist schwere der in
hunt ist am schwersten der elefant ist
am schwersten
halt halt an halten sie an
sie an
halt
ist gesünder
essen sie gesünder
v
stieg war vorsichtig fahren sie
vorsichtig fahren sie vorsichtig fahrt
vorsichtig fahrt vorsichtig sei
leise leise
seien
die leise
sei
sie leise
seit leise seit leise was deine hände
wasche seine hände waschen sie ihre
hände
was
ihre hände
wascht eure hände wasche hält
pass auf
passen sie auf
passt auf passt auf trink weniger
alkohol
trinkt weniger alkohol
trinken sie mehr wasser
trinkt wie
bier
der bier
steh auf steh auf stehen sie auf stehen
sie auf steht auf steht auf geht
geradeaus bis zur kreuzung dann rechts
die geradeaus bis zur kreuzung dann
rechts
gehen sie bei der nächsten kreuzung nach
geht jetzt nach hause geht jetzt nach
hause
öffne bitte die garagentür
öffne bitte die garagentür öffnen sie
bitte die tür öffnen sie bitte die tür
öffnet nie eine e mail von dir den
absender nicht kennt
öffnet nie eine e mail von der ihr den
nimm doch ein taschentuch
nehmen sie das medikament jeden tag
nimmt
drogen
nehmt keine drogen
das sofa kostet 2008 130 franken
die jacke kostet 5 125 franken
der stuhl kostet nur 99 franken
die kissen kosten nur 27 franken pro
stück
die tasche ist aus leder die tat
ist aus leder der tisch ist aus holz
der tisch ist aus holz
dass fans
ist aus glas
das fenster ist aus glas
das messer ist aus metall
das messer ist aus metall die teller
sind aus plastik detail
sind aus plastik